the jogan experience I caught the gun
charge that uh that that that triggered
the felony that allowed them to be able
to sentence me the way that they did in
1994 um I also caught another case at
that time I was G I was I was what you
call um giving out consignment on
drugs um two people in particular I gave
Consignment to and I ended up getting
arrested for a case um and when I sent
someone to go pick up the money from
them they kind of just was like you know
n whatever I'm not paying them so when I
came home um one guy in particular I ran
into him with his girlfriend he did you
get that case got dismissed right the
gun charge no the one that you were away
for you got arrested for something
you're in jail yes these guys figure
since you're in jail [__] it we're not
going to pay him yeah I'm not going to
pay and then the case that you were
arrested for got to got dismissed I got
so then you come home so I come home and
you know I need my
money I I need my money I'm just just is
just me being honest this is Miss being
straight you know I gave you
something and we had an understanding
that you were going to pay me and when I
came home when I finally located this
particular individual he had his
girlfriend with him um and this guy owed
me $5,000 for some drugs that I had gave
him on consignment I gave him a eighth
eighth of a kilo which is 125 gram of
cocaine
um and when I saw him he had a bunch of
jewelry on he was with his girlfriend
she had a bunch of jewelry on and I said
hey
man where's my money at oh y' I was
going to pay
you as far as I was concerned his jewy
was we was even so I robbed him and I
took his jewry and his girlfriend had
happened to be there and um
unfortunately she got caught up in the
situation I had a bunch of young guys
with me and they robbed her as well and
he got hit in the head with the gun
right here on the side of his head and
he got two
stitches and they gave me 25 years for
that case did you hit him in the head no
one of the guys that I was with hit him
in the head
um and he identified me in a photo array
unbeknownst to me he identified me in a
photo array um this guy you know as far
as I was concerned he was in the streets
just like I was so right I didn't really
understand that you know like I said we
go back to morals and values and
principles and how warped they can be
right in my mind at the time this is a
guy who I gave something to he's living
an illegal life I'm living an illegal
life so as far as I was concerned at
that time it was fair game and hindsight
as I as I moved on and I became more
mature and I began to re-evaluate myself
I realized how wrong that was but that
was later on at this time I committed
the crime and I just kept
moving another guy that I ran into he
also owed me some money he owed me
$7,000 and it kind of went along the
same ways he was selling drugs out of an
auto part
store he was a Spanish guy um I got word
that this is where he was at and he was
selling drugs and I was going to get my
money and the same circumstances kind of
ensued saw him hey what's going on you
know um reading in between the lines and
outside the margins without really going
into all of the details I robbed him
because he owed me
$77,000 did he get physically hurt no he
didn't get touched got roughed up a
little bit but there was no physical
there was no physical
harm
nothing um going back to and morals and
values and principles right in my mind
he was fair game he's selling drugs I'm
selling drugs you owe me money I came to
take what you have in that world that
was considered as permissible these are
one of the rules of something that was
permissible in that World
um long story short um in December 1997
I get arrested for both cases really for
one of them for the uh one with the guy
and the girl um
and then the other case drops with the
auto par store the guy that I said that
was selling drugs out of the auto par
store
um I am in the process of going to court
I'm going back and forth to court I'm on
Riker Island at the time it's just crazy
on Riker Island um that's when The Gangs
was involved uh prior to that a year
before that I hadn't got involved with
the gangs I was I was blood I was a gang
member this where the cut come from on
my face I have a bunch of stab marks
from just being in those environments
and being on rer island and just
um Waring with other rival gangs U
mostly Latin Kings and
Nas
um my final offer before trial was 23
years which kind of blew me away because
my lawyer kept telling me that my
maximum sentence was 25 years if I went
to trial so on my mind I it just didn't
make no sense to me why would I forfeit
my rights to an appeal if it's only a
two-year
difference um I told the judge I would
take 15 years right
now I acknowledged that I had that I had
made some mistakes and I had done some
things that that were wrong and I said
I'll take 15 years right
now he refused to uh accept my plea
offer and I went to trial and that I
ended up getting 50
years 5 Z and um
so they give you 25 for each case is
that 25 for each
case
consecutive
um so and I remember
um I remember like blowing trial and
just not really understanding like what
was being there but not like it was like
almost surreal and I remember when I
went and got sting and the judge said 50
years now mind you I I had a black
lawyer a black judge and a white process
cutor
um and I remember when he said 50 years
he said I he went into all of
these
um reasons why he was sentencing me the
way that he was sentencing me um there
was never no post uh there was never no
uh uh they're supposed to do a report
prior to your sentencing and it's called
Uh post supervision
interview um pre-sentencing inter
investigation it's called the PSI
pre-sentencing investigation there was
never no pre-sentencing investigation
there was never no mitigating evidence
presented on my behalf to you know
highlight why I may have made some of
the decisions that I made um and he just
called me a minister society and he just
he gave me 50 years and I remember when
I um when I first got to down state
which is a processing facility and they
give you what they call is a Time
computation sheet and on the time
computation she gives you all of the
numbers like the beginning of your bid
how much jail time you have um and I
just remember 2049 that's all I kept
looking
at and I was like
2049 are they [__]
serious this is 1998
1999 and I'm trying to do the math and
I'm just like 20 49 I'm like that's 50
years from
now and I remember going to the L
library and um I forget how I get the
world
armac and something just says look up
the life expectancy and I look up my
life expectancy and as an
African-American man my life expectancy
at that time was 67 years old and I did
the math and I said I'm going to die in
prison
man I just really believed that I was
going to die in
prison um one thing I learned really
really quickly when I got to prison was
that prison does two things to you it
brings out the best or it brings out the
worst and what I saw was I saw
individuals who were at their worst and
I saw guys who were at their
best um the guys who were at their best
were guys who were involved in education
postsecondary education programs they
were running the pro they was running
the violence groups they was running the
substance abuse groups
um and I remember saying to myself
myself I want
that and I remember just being involved
in so much [__] because I was in a
gang and um I was I was I was top of the
food chain I had my own Nation I wasn't
just like the random gang member I had a
whole nation under me um and I was just
in and out the box in and out the box
solitary confinement which has been
considered as unconstitutional now um um
and I remember just having these moments
of reflection and just asking myself
like what are you going to
do can you spend the next 48 years
living like
this I said I couldn't do it and I
um I had lost all my privileges they
took everything from me I was in
Southport at the time which is closed
now uh it's a solitary confinement
facility in New York state and and um I
was on a loaf which is also
unconstitutional now so the loaf is uh a
dietary restriction that they give you
it's a chunk of bread and it has cabbage
and carrots in it and they give you like
a quarter of a cabbage and they give you
a cup of milk when they can't take any
more of your privileges this is what
they would give you six days out the
week on the seventh day you would get a
hot meal breakfast lunch and dinner and
then it would go back for 21 days they
would do this six and one six and one
six and one and it was at that moment
where I I really said I have to change
my
life I have to change my life I I just
can't do this um I had a wife I had
family still my son was growing up um he
was hearing stories about my so-call uh
notoriety and um I just didn't want to I
just didn't want to be that
dad like I really was looking at myself
and really evaluating asking myself like
yo what the [__] are you
doing I was still I was smoking a lot of
weed at the time I was drinking um jail
house
Hooch um and I was at my
worst and I and I had to real I had to
figure out how to get to my best so I
decided to when I got out of salitary
confinement um I did 42 days on a loaf I
I went from two being 210 pounds to like
168 in like a matter of 7 months
deflated me um and when I got out I made
a decision that I was going to walk away
and I didn't care about what the
consequences was and I said to myself
I've been doing bad for so long I'm
going to try to do something
good if all else fails I could always go
back to doing bad but let me try let me
give it a shot um and I ended up getting
to school program I got my GED um I left
the gangs alone which was a benefit for
them because you know I was what you
call an authoritarian I was a rule guy
I'm I'm still a rule guy I like rules
you know I like rules I like structure I
like things to be a certain way um and
it was to their advantage to get rid of
me anyway plus I knew a lot of the guys
who were at the top why was it to their
advantage to get rid of you because I
was the type of person who would
say you doing that for what reason n you
can't do that the rule says that you
can't do this you can't do this this is
what the rules say and I was the rules
of the prison or the rules of the street
gang the rules of the streets yeah there
was rules give us a for instance okay so
for instance
uh I could be in a whole another
facility let's say I'm in Green Haven
and a guy's in Attica and they want to
do something to him because they feel
like he's not sharing his
proceeds of drugs that he's bringing
into the facility the rule say you can't
do
that that's his property that's his
belongings so I was a rule guy and they
just you know it was to their advantage
to get me out of the way so when I
decided to take a step back they were
like
yes and it was to my advantage as well
um and this was in 2005 so there was no
resistance
none and at that time this is where lot
of the uh what they call set tripping
began uh the the the organization began
to implode on
itself the gang organization the gang
organization there was a lot of
infighting sets against sets and I was
just always against
that um and it was time for me to go and
I I didn't care whatever the
consequences was I was fortunate that
there weren't any consequences
um but I didn't care what the
consequences was I just walked away and
then that begins your journey this
begins my journey I got into school I
got my
GED um from there I got involved in um
correspondence courses I started
interacting with guys who were teaching
art aggression replacement training and
I started to begin to understand how
these Concepts Works what's positive
visualization is um deep breathing how
to remove yourself conflict resolution
all of these ideas of of change began to
take place with me um
substance abuse I stopped smoking weed I
stopped smoking cigarettes I was smoking
like 30 cigarettes a day I I mean I'm
literally having chest pains from
smoking cigarettes and I realized that I
wanted to live and the only way that I
was going to be able to live and walk
out of prison was to remove myself from
these
substances